[Music]
[Applause]
[Music] It
's not the first representative of Shichionsha Co., Ltd.
A music game called PaRappa the Rapper The 10's is a conscious office worker.
At first, it's
a play called Guitar Le Mans.
Well, I
think it's possible to give a little bird to something other than rhythm because PaRappa the Rappa entered the game industry
with the first inspiration.  We are a
new music game project, PaRappa the Rough, and
I think the first big unique point of this game is to create a music game based on the story that we are most good at
.  The view of the world
is a fact of Japan's old history, isn't it? It's a story.
At the same time,
it's a unique world that fuses a futuristic high-tech world
.  Follows
the basics of a teenage basic rhythm game of pressing a button at the timing of the music,
but based on the ambition to advance with the music game system of this game
.
The
battle player and the opponent who battles alternately raise their hearts, but
especially the recent 8 rpg and the dimmer-inspired music
feel, dialogue
, and emotions.  It's because users don't think about what they want to express.
8 Well, in the form of lap battle,
I think there was probably no game that controls such lyric and words in a form close to real time
.
Well, it's really exactly one of the things that PaRappa the Rapper made.
Well
, it's said that it's a rhythm game though it's a rap-themed game, although it's a bit more of an act when I made a daddy.
That's not a lap game, isn't it? That criticism is that, oh, that's just you, is
n't it? Well, that's true, but that
game of this project.  I think that the system of is an app game.
Please give me a new challenger.
I've received a lot of it, but I haven't had a way or a chance to realize it
.  But this time
, I think it's the first time for me to work with you on this kickstarter project, and I think you'll have a chance to realize
it. I hope you'll join us and enjoy it with us.
Let's make it a two-person medical college